[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition de votre journal local
voici les titres de ce jeudi à 6 avril
favoriser le rapprochement entre
domicile et travail c'est l'un des
objectifs de la nouvelle convention
habitat signé par l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines
ce document doit faciliter notamment le
parcours résidentiel sur le territoire
1,5 million de personnes étaient
concernées il ya cinq ans ils seront
peut-être plus à se laisser tenter dans
18 jours le vote par procuration un
moyen de lutter contre l'abstention est
une démarche simplifiée via internet
c'est un ballet d'eau et de musique
devenue un rituel depuis 350 ans les
grandes eaux musicales ont débuté dans
le parc du château de versailles
une idée de sortie en pleines vacances
scolaires et alors que le soleil
s'installe sur la région parisienne
jusqu'à la fin de semaine
s'adapter aux différentes étapes de la
vie professionnelle en aidant le
parcours résidentiel l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines a signé hier
une nouvelle convention cadre en matière
d'habitat celle ci sera effective
jusqu'en 2020 et doit aider notamment
les plus jeunes à accéder à la propriété
les précisions avec ce reportage
d'haussmann avant garde et avec cette
nouvelle convention avec l'organisme
action logement
saint quentin en yvelines oeuvre pour le
rapprochement habitat emploi
on lance une
une opération avec des acteurs
spécialisés dans pour mieux accompagner
les demandes de logement pour mieux
informer donc donc le beau objectif
c'est qu'ils sont d'améliorer l'offre de
logement et pour qu'elles correspondent
encore plus aux attentes des salariés
des entreprises
bien sûr de l'agglomération de saint
quentin seuls 35% des salariés qui
travaillent sur le territoire y habitent
le but de l'opération est d'atteindre
50% en 2020 l'agglomération souhaite
aussi les attirer grâce à ces atouts
nous leur offrons je dirais une vie en
dehors du travail une vie assez intense
que ce soit d'un point de vue culturel
sportif de loisirs
c'est une saint quentin en yvelines
c'est quand même une communauté
d'agglomération très très verte très
diversifiée où on peut s'épanouir sur
son temps libre et donc ça c'est déjà je
dirais une façon d'accueillir mes
salariés et de les fidéliser sur notre
territoire des jeunes actifs à la
session aidée à la propriété en passant
par le logement intermédiaire
cette convention a pour but d'aider les
salariés à chaque étape de la vie
professionnelle à voisins le bretonneux
une nouvelle étape a été franchie dans
le déploiement de la fibre optique la
maire de la commune alexandra rosetti et
les représentants de la société orange
ont inauguré hier un nouveau dispositif
à proximité de la mairie celui ci permet
à plus de 350 logements de bénéficier
d'un débit 30 à 40 fois supérieur à
l'adsl
au total dix sept armoires de ce type
seront installés dans la ville d'ici la
fin de l'année et deux sont déjà actives
écouter l'un des responsables d'orange
au micro de miquel et demi d'euros dès
aujourd'hui on adapte de laquelle vous
parle on a déjà plus de 650 logements
qui sont éligibles à la pio on a déjà un
certain nombre d'habitants qui ont même
souscrit des abonnements à la fibre mais
l'objectif est bien évident que
l'ensemble des logements de la ville de
voisins-le-bretonneux soit éligible
quand je dis les logements se sont aussi
bien les particuliers les commerçants
les entreprises les professions
libérales on à densifier le réseau a
minima à raison d'une fibre par logement
direction guyancourt à présent ou la
piscine municipale est fermée au public
depuis lundi pour cause de travaux une
fermeture exceptionnelle de huit
semaines dans tout pour remplacer
notamment la chaudière le réseau de
douche est également rénové une
situation qui empêche certains cours de
natation d'être assurée jusqu'à la fin
mai le coût total de ces travaux est
évalué à 220 mille euros les précisions
de florence coquard chargé des sports à
guyancourt la chaudière elles datent de
1994 auquel à 23 ans elle est utilisée
24 heures sur 24 7 jours sur 7 sauf les
jours de quand on fait les vidanges à
guyancourt donc deux fois par an donc
bah là elle est à bout de souffle
elle a 23 ans donc il faut dire ça dure
à peu près 20 ans donc là il fallait
vraiment la changer on a prévenu le club
dès qu'on a su qu'on allait engager la
procédure des travaux
bien sûr on n'a pas pu le faire
officiellement parce que tant que les
appels d'offres sont pas passées on peut
pas annoncer officiellement une
fermeture mais le savait depuis le mois
de juin donc après c'est toujours
compliqué pour eux aussi de s'organiser
pour pour les cours donc voilà on
essayait minimiser l'impact
et sachez à ce propos que sur le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
cinq autres piscines reste ouverte pour
vos envies de longues heures pour
connaître les horaires d'ouverture les
tarifs et les adresses rendez vous sur
www.itsgroup.fr et cliquer sur l'onglet
loisirs présidentielle législative pas
moins de quatre scrutins sont prévus
cette année en 2017 et 47 millions de
français ont tous sont amenés à se
prononcer pour choisir leur nouveau
président et leurs députés
particularité cette année le deuxième
tour de la présidentielle par exemple ce
jour à la veille d'un jour férié et
certains d'entre vous seront peut-être
en vacances ou absents si vous souhaitez
quand même donner votre voix une
solution existe la procuration
mais alors où faut-il se rendre est ce
compliqué quels documents remplira les
explications avec ce sujet de mélanie
poké plus que 18 jours avant le premier
tour des présidentielles
si vous ne pouvez pas vous déplacer dans
un bureau de vote vous pouvez donner
procuration pour cela rien de plus
simple
le document cerfa est disponible sur
internet
devais choisir une personne de confiance
le mandant celui qui votera pour vous
doit être inscrit dans la même commune
une fois le document rempli il faut
alors se rendre au commissariat à la
gendarmerie ou encore au tribunal
d'instance avec une pièce d'identité
la procuration peut être fait jusqu'à la
veille du scrutin un délai théorique
pour des raisons d'acheminement postaux
il est préférable de le prévoir
plusieurs jours à l'avance lors des
élections présidentielles de 2012
un million et demi de personnes avaient
voté par procuration des ateliers
ludiques sur le développement durable ce
sont les activités qu'a proposé la
mairie de trappes jusqu'à hier pour la
semaine de l'environnement
enfants et parents ont notamment pu se
sensibiliser au tri des déchets aux
économies d'énergie thomas hardy et le
maire-adjoint en charge de
l'environnement à trappes il était au
micro de miquel et demi d'eau alors
l'objectif premier c'est de la formation
l'information et la sensibilisation
autour de l'écologie du quotidien les
gestes notamment de tri les gestes tu le
disais autour de l'eau de l'électricité
de du respect du patrimoine commun
l'espace public
voilà notamment ce message et les porter
au regard des urgences qui sont celles
de la planète mais aussi au niveau très
local et de façon très pratico pratique
pour avoir des économies sur la facture
de d'électricité d'eau je disais voilà
donc on est sûr de l'information avant
tout de la sensibilisation
on peut clairement parler d'une
renaissance pour la section de l'union
nationale des combattants de maurepas
créé en 1920 en 1924
celle ci avait disparu durant la
deuxième guerre mondiale
hier sur le parvis de l'hôtel de ville
les soixante douze sections de lune et
c'est des yvelines sont venus assister à
la remise du drapeau à la section mort
pas yens
un geste symbolique pour ce collectif de
42 adhérents écoutez c'est un beau jour
c'est en même temps une fleur une fierté
et puis perdurer le devoir de mémoire
est quelque chose d'extrêmement
important surtout à l'époque où on vit
aujourd'hui je pense qu'avec l'énergie
et la volonté de la présidente qui a
fait ses preuves pendant trois mois aux
quatre mois que cette section udc va
encore perdurer bien longtemps
maintenant et va surtout augmenté des
effectifs de façon à pouvoir montrer
population que le devoir de mémoire et
de drapeaux ce n'est pas rien et qu'il
faut les respecter
une idée de sortie à présent pour ces
vacances scolaires de pâques et cette
habitude à chaque printemps dans le parc
du château de versailles les fontaines
quittent leur sommeil hivernal pour les
grandes eaux musicales un spectacle
magique pour les visiteurs du monde
entier et qui ont débuté le week-end
dernier dans les jardins de louis xiv
reportage
[Musique]
l'arrivée du printemps et des beaux
jours semblent comme réveiller les
fontaines du parc de versailles
après une pause de cinq mois l'eau
jaillit à nouveau dans un jardin
spectaculaire de 77 hectares imaginé il
ya 350 ans par le roi soleil et qui
éblouit toujours autant les yeux des
visiteurs qui se créent les autres c'est
vraiment impressionnant et magnifique
tout le travail qui a été réalisé vaut
le coup les gens du monde entier peuvent
venir et apprécier le spectacle
c'est une vraie bénédiction les grandes
eaux musicales parfait endroit pour se
balader et profitez en musique du décor
boisé du château de versailles
au total 55 fontaine sont à découvrir
et parmi les nouveautés cette année le
bassin des enfants doré créé en 1709
elle aura encore plus de sens d'ici
quelques semaines quand son écrin de
verdure a littéralement lui faire un
panneau arrière un fond vert
on dirait autour d'elle elle va soudain
ressortir encore mieux il ya vraiment
cette pensée du début à la fin
c'est une des salles de plus du château
le château de versailles il ya de
l'intérieur il ya de l'extérieur traités
avec le même soin et peut-être à
l'époque avec le même budget tellement
les fontaines coûter cher la réussite de
ce concert d'eau et de verdure serait
impossible sans eux les fontainiers ils
sont treize arpenter les sols et les
sous sols du château depuis le xviiie
siècle la méthode reste la même avec une
clé à lire j'ai un an fait de poser ma
clé de manette dessus pour pouvoir
tourner la clé qui permet d'ouvrir les
vannes et ainsi faire jaillir l'eau dans
la fontaine des enfants doré c'est
l'aboutissement déjà du travail qu'on a
eu en amont pour tout préparer toutes
les fontaines pour justement le
spectacle des grandes villes
faire plaisir aux gens et voilà il
perpétue aussi un geste ancestral plus
de 70 représentations des grandes eaux
musicales sont prévues jusqu'au 29
octobre prochain
onur une page de culture à présent avec
une nouvelle forme d'improvisation
attrape ce week-end l'école de musique
et de danse accueilli un match
d'improvisation littéraire deux équipes
s'affronter sur des textes rédigés en
direct sur un ordinateur
à l'origine la société ad de production
et un certain papilles nicolas landry
s'est glissée dans la salle trappistes
regarder alors le mythe c'est la scène
est en ligne les adversaires deux
équipes de catcheur et leurs arbres un
texte écrit en direct c'est le principe
du chaos des mots c'est particulier il
faut arriver déjà à a dépassé de
simplement son blocage à l'écrit et dans
capacité à pouvoir s'amuser du clavier
et laisser libre cours à son imaginaire
par rapport à ce qui est posée donc par
exemple au premier rand
on donne un équipes it c'est à dire la
première phrase d'un roman et il va
falloir continuer pendant cinq minutes
ce roman là parmi les joueurs des jeunes
issus de l'association escaladent qui
lutte contre le décrochage scolaire
on se reconnaître dans le plaisir à
écrire et redonner plaisir à des gens
qui ont effectivement peut-être des
difficultés qui sont pas reconnus dans
leur écriture là d'un seul coup y ont
leur offre cette possibilité là de se
connecter avec bonheur et avec plaisir
elle des difficultés ajouté à chaque
round des pénalités en fonction des
fautes et pourquoi pas découvrir
l'écrivain de demain
et on referme ce journal sur ces images
de bottens tourner cet après midi au
parc des sources de la bièvre à
guyancourt
de nombreuses personnes ont profité du
soleil et de la fraîcheur ambiante
et bonne nouvelle cela devrait durer
jusqu'à la fin de la semaine
météo france prévoit même jusqu'à 20
degrés ce week end en région parisienne
c'est la fin de ce 7 8 le journal merci
de nous avoir suivi tous nos reportages
sont à retrouver en replay sur notre
site internet tv fil 78 points comme ou
l'application tv fils beau bonne soirée
à tous et excusez moi
[Musique]